vacciner vacciner vacciner triptyque
préféré des manuels macron ces dernières
24 heures le chef de l'état n'a cessé
d'appeler les français à prendre rendez
vous mais attention un calendrier est
toujours à respecter
vous avez 18 ans ou plus et vous êtes
vulnérable dès ce week end
vous pouvez vous faire vacciner prenez
rendez vous sur sante.fr vous avez 50
ans ou plus ce rendez vous le 15 mai
pour vous faire vacciner vous avez 18
ans au plus rendez vous le 15 juin pour
vous faire vacciner des directives
adressées depuis paris et l'elysée mais
une réalité tout autre dans le reste de
l'hexagone
exemple à bastia et porticcio en corse
face à l'excès de doses les élus ont
décidé d'élargir la vaccination à tous
les jeunes sans distinction dans un but
aussi économiques
al'approche de la saison estivale et
d'autres communes tentent également de
contourner des problèmes administratifs
contraignant les pénalisant à l'image de
cette annonce mercredi du maire de
quillan dans le sud de la france une
vaccination ouverte sans limite d'âge
démentie dans la foulée par l' agence
régionale de santé d'occitanie et la
préfecture de l'aude
une suppression des critères de
priorisation souhaiter de plus en plus
par un certain nombre d'élus et deux
médecins pour que la vaccination gagne
en importance il faut deux conditions
ouvrir plus de centres de vaccination et
mettre en place des moyens mobiles pour
aller vers les personnes isolées
vacciner tout le monde en ouvrant les
créneaux à tous le gouvernement a eu
raison d'avoir des priorités de vacciner
les plus fragiles
maintenant on entre dans une deuxième
vague de vaccination où il faut être
pragmatique
dès qu'une dose n'est pas utilisé il
faut l'injecter un public non
prioritaires qui tentent également le
plus souvent sa chance dans les
vaccinodromes onf en journée lieu où des
milliers de personnes de se faire
vacciner
quotidiennement j'ai vraiment envie de
protéger mes proches donc je trouve que
c'est important de si c'est possible
d'éviter au maximum d'être contaminés
sur tout contaminer les autres
j'ai 20 ans je suis étudiant donc sur
marseille j'habite juste à côté et puis
je m'étais dit voilà il ya le centre si
le soir il peut rester des 11 au moins
s'est fait plutôt qu'à 30 juin selon le
ministre de la santé olivier véran sur
550 milles vaccination réalisée jeudi
dix mille ne correspondaient pas à des
personnes prioritaires
face aux critiques le porte parole du
gouvernement l'a martelé vendredi la
vaccination sera un succès collectif si
elle est réalisée en bon ordre